[Music]
[Music]
fire
stop
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby all right chingas
the galaxy shirt on oh that's a nice
galaxy shirt dude is that the Milky Way
no I don't know oh you just like the way
it looks you're a little chilly chill
chill huh that's the I mean what I don't
know what they see is in there but it is
chilly yeah your boys and your boys in
Denver
went to Denver on bad term you know not
there for a few reason funeral ground
passed away at nine to eight my dad
during the ceremony goes taking too soon
and I
I went I mean are you saying this for
the podcast or is that true no it's true
and I went I looked down at my family
like this I went
I just did you know how we do that with
our neck I went like this and went and
everyone's bust out laughing I went
Dad Dad
but he had to he had to like organize
and do the whole thing you know yeah so
you know he's probably nervous whatever
he didn't mean that but it was good so
you're talking but that's one of eleven
all the obviously all the children uh my
grandma's kids are there and then the
grandchildren there and
great-grandchildren so your time out
Generations yeah that's a legacy I mean
98 over 100 people yeah just a shop just
shops shot just balls deep in shops wow
maybe realize I'm like oh [ __ ] when she
wouldn't come back enough when she was
born women had just gotten the vote yeah
that gives you some old school and they
were showing uh they had like the whole
like collage of her when she was younger
god dog Dime Piece well you know your
mom's a dime piece yeah your mom has is
a beautiful woman I like that picture
you sent I think you posted on Instagram
I post I posted cheekbones dude I posted
a video because my mom broke her legs
spiral fracture horrible horrible injury
oh my God but I get them you know she
watches all the podcasts and stuff she's
talking about Theo leaving and uh you
know she loves Theo and loves all you
guys there she is and then she's like I
go she goes uh fill me in like we
haven't talked what's going on with
touring and I was like what do you mean
it starts up next week mom big big
touring up major cities you know we go
to Boston and Salt Lake and Calgary and
all that and she's like oh yeah it's
Mark Harley gonna be there I'm like what
she gets Mark Harley and being like he's
on the road you know he does all the
stuff for me she goes oh man
just let me get through the dates and
you do your thing right I didn't see it
yeah and so I'm doing I thought it was
just a picture no no no no no oh bring
that video get younger though you a
little bit right bring that up
and uh Denver visiting my family I'm
here at my mama's house you guys should
know your boy's hitting the road after I
leave uh
I didn't tell her anything in Boston
next week next Thursday just let me just
scroll through I didn't watch the spot I
was like I don't care then after that
October 13th to the 15th I'm in San Jose
come get some San Jose then right after
that I am in Salt Lake City Utah Wise
Guys are my favorite my mom just
chilling I'm sorry in October in Calgary
Calgary's the total 7th and 28th come
get something bigboy.com
hey Brett so is Mark Carly gonna be
there too with you I mean yeah yeah he's
on them watch out red by Facebook oh my
God he is such a stud muffin Mark I have
a broken ankle right now but if you were
here and I didn't have this broken ankle
I'd be jumping all over you boy
um look at my face I've read it oh boy
this is weird you guys out there
can you blame her that's great I'll be
jumping all over you boy I went well
don't come boy yeah Marcus she's just
she was older women are you up yeah it's
one of my demographics gay guys black
women gay guys women yeah black women
like you they'll at least verbalize it
that's the only demographic of women who
will stop me in the street or something
like gay dudes in black women like you
cute like but nobody else says that I
love that you know but then a lot of
women will go oh I just want to touch
your hair I'm like it feels like hair
man like what do you what do you mean
well they see the whole package you look
like you're you are the guy on the
romance novel that's what it is yes and
my mom was looking and she's gonna play
that my mom's trying to [ __ ]
there are women like my mother like so
like she'd be like look at how muscular
women are drawn to that yeah so a lot of
women are drawn to shoulders be repulsed
I don't think well with you it's not
because your frame is big and you're
tall how tall are you
um let me get my hands down my pants
well with Mark there's no either he's
women's like Vibe and they're obsessed
with them or they're like oh disgusting
like there's no middle ground with him
yeah they're either and that's okay he's
either the hottest guy in the world or
they're just not he's not there yeah I'm
not the archetype every girl has
archetypes
you have a certain look yeah you're
divisive I don't know is is that okay so
so I think first of all they're drawn to
your your they they see the thighs
physique they see the thighs they see
the nurses pants they said they go that
guy that they go that guy's got a pile
driver for an ass he's got strong
[ __ ] legs then they go up to the body
well no they assume it has a big dick to
go 100 the thigh deep voice it's got the
deep voice packing heat yep a big old
creatine dick yeah and so yeah you're
you're a big boom you're a vava Voom guy
it marks a lot it's a lot that's a lot
and then when you talk to them like
Jesus Christ March just and it's it's
great he's just you know and he's he's
big hands or thick fingers entertaining
like just like a tidal wave of silver
and I'm okay over the years I've become
okay with like you're not going to be
for everyone and that's okay nobody is
the other people right nobody maybe you
take offense like before it's like oh I
wonder why this person doesn't like me
and it's like well look at how you
behave and look yeah yeah
speaking of bigger my shoes trying to
[ __ ] yeah yeah well let's say hey Mom
listen oh no dude before we I went to a
high school football game so klopp is
the tight ends coach and I think part
offense coordinator for Arapahoe High
School yeah so years we have a game
Friday I want to call you not really I
think it's please come I was like let's
do it so I went to hang out with his
family and he has two little girls right
here haven't seen forever I haven't been
a high school football game in a hot
second I got there and uh collapse
friends go what do you think of too many
whites it's too many whites not there's
gonna be no scholarships given to
anybody out here everyone's laughing but
then there was one big black kid on the
other team and this dude [ __ ] went
off I mean it was like plexigo burst I
mean just jumping over these little
white dudes touchdowns he'd look like he
played for USC Jesus just dominating you
can kind of see it high school but yeah
you can see it and then collapse team
it's so it's clops on the team right
played NFL for a number of years all big
12. he's the biggest freak I've ever
seen
nothing just lifting weights you're not
just doing he's like ah nothing crazy
he's just you got to see him Mark you
freak out dude he's [ __ ] he's on
Sidelines he looks exactly like Dan
Campbell on steroids but he's not but
he's not Joe klopfenstein good luck he
was there's I believe he's natural he's
all natural I believe oh dude he but no
he has no idea fast food uh he you know
he told me he goes dude you're gonna
freak out I thought he had like some
cool info for me about like C football
something goes dude you like ice cream
like you know kind of he goes dude you
know it doesn't spike your insulin he's
like because it's so much fat in it so
you eat it late at night right because
sometimes he goes dude I eat it I eat
tubs and I'm oh okay it's [ __ ] cool
right yeah it's an interesting he's six
five looking 265.
and when I tell you he's like he's he
looks like the guy from The Incredibles
he's got like eight ABS with the biggest
[ __ ] arm you can tell he's yeah he's
got a lot of natural musculature his
abdomen he's always good that way he's
the biggest freak so that's one that's
why when people go oh whatever steroids
he is not there you go no he just looks
like he has a gigantic frame to begin
with oh he's math he's six six look at
him yeah and just lean like he was lean
in high school and then put on weight
yeah and I remember in college when I
was like oh he's gonna go pretty high in
the NFL draft we're playing UTEP in uh
some ball game and he freaking kind of
touched them or yeah he caught a uh like
a scene route up the middle and the guy
guarding him was supposed to go in the
first round and he just [ __ ] starched
them he ran a four low like he ran a
four five seven in the 40 at 260 pounds
that's so [ __ ] weird yeah looking at
him stand next to you yeah he's way
bigger than Brennan he makes you look
really skinny that's what my girl said
my girl those I've never seen you look
small she was next to clap like you
looked like me look at his legs look at
his [ __ ] legs his legs and [ __ ]
because he looks proportional too like
you wouldn't look at him and think he's
six six out of context that's the thing
every like his thighs are big he's
always that giant guy there that guy
that's Elliott Marshall I'll tell you
yeah no he's just a freak and then so
he's doing this uh
High School coaching dude the demand of
that and you know he he's one of the
real success stories that played
professional sports and then parlayed
into this hugely successful career in
real estate he flips houses and does all
that so he's crushing it with that so
then he has two little girls but then he
loves football so then uh Tyler Brayton
used to play with us he played in the
NFL this is their coach of stuff Tyler
Brayton first round draft pick CU buff
uh lump like All-Star alumni first round
draft pick for the Raiders freak freak
bigger freaking clap freak so he's the
head coach claps your [ __ ] offense
coordinator you have the Alvin Barnett
who was the receiver at Sea so you have
all these studs you know you have all
these freaking studs yeah it's
ridiculous but he uh the out that's my
thing with coaching like my buddy Paul
Creighton is a coach at Washington now I
think he's uh offensive coordinate or
something like that who was our roommate
and I have a bunch of college buddies or
coaches now you want to talk about hours
dude you're 40 hours they laugh at that
you mean the players are the the coaches
coaches They're laughing at that there's
no there's no off time like you're doing
in season it's and this is for high
school you're saying for high school if
you're like up offense Corner head coach
defense square and up it's like a
nightmare dude so the cops like dude
I've worked seven days a week like 6 a.m
We gotta go over the on Sunday I gotta
come in go over the game tape and come
up the game plan for the phone week wow
I'm just like for and he did and he
doesn't he elected not to get paid he's
like take the money and donate it I'm
good on that he just loves it I'm like
God bless you man God bless you that
coaching is not so smooth so the funeral
was uh
funeral is good because you saw I have
so many aunts and uncles who haven't
seen literally in 20 years everybody
looks different it's all cousins I
haven't seen and since they were tiny
like my cousin Dalton when I saw him
literally he was he was a cute little
cat like Boston well that was probably
22 years ago he's a full grown man oh I
was like who are you he's like Dalton
like holy [ __ ] he's all big and in shape
what the [ __ ] you're Dalton dude crazy
I'm like talking to like other my
cousin's kids and [ __ ] it was it was
interesting man B can we take a little
break from chat about this nonsense
dude oh you got a cool stain on your
jeans yeah I just saw that I just saw
that I don't know
I'm a road dog you're a road dog it
looks like an [ __ ] it might be
somebody rub their ass off somebody sat
with the with it without pants after poo
poo and they sat right there that's
exactly what that looks like it looks
like it looks like a poop of a [ __ ]
it's a poop I said hey bro you done
pulling worry about toilet paper come
cop a squad on my on my lap no you know
you'd be a little more agile if you're
doing some proper things like athletic
greens dude because I thought greens I
couldn't put my poop around your jeans
keeping up with like all the pills what
you're supposed to do it does the work
for you one scoop of ag1 scoop dude
minerals Whole Foods sourced ingredients
the superfood multivitamin you got a
multi-mineral you got a probiotic you
got green superfood blend and more it's
all in one one syrup it's my favorite
supplement I ran out of it please send
more please send more it's my favorite
dude it's awesome join the movement of
athletes moms dads aunts gay uncles
rookies podcasters comedians we're all
on it baby vegan yes dairy free
gluten-free and to make it easy I
thought Green's gonna give you immune
supporting free one year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com fighter today again
all you gotta do to get the best
curriculum freaking supplement on the
planet go to athleticgreens.com fighter
take control of your health and give ag1
a try
you know it's big speaking of big
[ __ ] uh Michael kiessa came to my
show
uh unspoken yeah he's from there okay
yeah great guy really good guy great guy
and uh well he walked in and he used to
fight at 155. I know he fights at 70 now
but he went to 70 uh every bit of six
too and he was 205 and I'm like how the
[ __ ] did you suck down that kind of
weight Savage dude Savage Savage [ __ ]
Savage such a good guy he lost his last
fight but he he was my uh
here's my Dark Horse to to you know take
over at 170. like this really mancha
once he's a Savage dude just wrestling
and [ __ ] his grappling's ridiculous
yeah so he lost he even told me in high
school he was a middling wrestler he was
a JV wrestler he had to hit a wrestle
for Varsity he wasn't good in high
school yeah and now you know but he
looked you look at his wins you know
Neil magni dos anjos uh Diego Sanchez
Carlos conda you know so he's fought the
who's who when he went back to Welter
where he ripped off four then he ran to
Vicente Luce got submitted and actually
had him beaten Vicente Luce and then
Sean Brady I don't know if you know
about Sean Brady but you should Brian I
know you don't but he's a kid from
Philly he's all tatted up looks like a
angel this boy's grappling is re bring
Sean Brady up because I've seen some
highlights you're not ready for him I
don't say seeing highlights that's fine
he's a freak yeah that kid
never seen in my life yeah no but you
should you'll see them more because he's
he's getting a big fight he he does big
fights coming up Jesus yeah he's
undefeated he's uh he cracked the top
ten he's out of Philly bro this dude no
he's a black belt in Jiu Jitsu Savage
really who's he fighting next Jen they
gave him a big name he's fighting at 70.
no not Neil no not Neil Neil's fighting
uh Rodriguez 70. 70 he's fighting 70.
thick boy
oh that's right to it UFC 280
it's a good fight for him he's
undefeated these Philly boys man they're
common yeah there's some killers
just show some Killers man
yeah he's a Savage constantly
yeah it's
is that him no it's here
he's just been waiting he just needs the
the big fights and you know
Jesus Muhammad's a good fight for him
Jesus look at that look at that tattoo
on the back of the Man Savage Thick
Growth to the Grave live your dash
that's another rule if you if you see a
guy in a [ __ ] bar you don't want to
fight him if he has a child when you
look at below next to him and my law is
a badass but you're just like is he yeah
is it yeah I didn't know that yeah he
was cutting weight there yeah so how to
Applause not I did a food truck with him
that's not what he said
to be honest his head his head so he
says 510 he had said he's six six
okay all right blog's just [ __ ] as
tough as they oh man what is his what
did he start with wrestling was he had
like an international kind of thing he's
from where Chicago what's his uh
National ethnicity
I think he's Arabic of some kind
Palestinian Iranian I think he might be
Palestinian or yeah Palestinian there
you go
wow
amazing
yeah but look out for Sean Brady yeah
yeah give on your radar get him on your
right get on your radar now really
Savage yeah
really interesting my nieces and nephews
wrestling for pictures at the funeral do
you want to in front of Grandma's uh urn
how do you want to do this do you want
to wait till after do you think that'd
be better yeah we can't smile you look
like we're having a grand old time let's
wait till after can we please wait after
yes can we please do that yeah
yeah
let's wait till after yeah good weekend
Spokane though I love Spokane we wanted
Tacoma next weekend it's [ __ ] right
back to action I love it that's a great
Club one of the best oh man they run a
great show and I hear uh Tacoma's great
too so have you not done Tacoma yet I
have not because you know Seattle was
always
um partly alive and now this is but I've
never done this y'all didn't have a club
now I know and this is what happened
we're outside of Seattle yeah there's
not a lot in Tacoma here it's nice
though yeah
Spokane's a little rough I'm not gonna
lie to you it's a little rough if you
stay downtown it's rough you're gonna
stay in Coeur d'Alene huh yes I get to
oh he's dead yeah Georgia State that's
the move hiki poo yeah went for a hiki
poo on my my toe holds and in sandals
sure did now here's the thing you want
to change I go no I'm going to hike in
my toes because I live you know I'm like
I wear my toe hoes they go I know but
it's up and I go ah [ __ ] off I get on
the trail and um
uh well then my foot catches fire
catches fire oh yeah sandals you're so
much smarter than this and I go ah I
kicked my sandal off and a yellow jacket
is just [ __ ] deep and you know the
the like so see I'm a yellow jacket one
in your big toe yes papa not even my my
middle toe in the soft part in the soft
region right where that squishy part
yeah cushion well where are my toe my my
digit meets my foot yeah the yellowjack
is stung you there oh he starts on me
real good and then are you sure a yellow
jacket we're talking about a wasp is it
actually Yellow Jacket the one with the
ABS and the hair no they so that's
they're like the Philly jacket it's just
a yellow jacket it's not but then I
realized I was in a nest of yellow
jackets you see so they're all buzzing
around and we [ __ ] I had to run then
I lost my thing my foot hurt yeah there
you go now now that [ __ ] right there
he's here though that [ __ ] I was
thinking something else nope that guy uh
hurt me my toe hurt for um I kept hiking
I almost I couldn't it was so painful I
go I'm gonna walk [ __ ] on it my foot
hurt for six hours to get you six
[ __ ] hours they get you yes and it
was it was it kind of this pulsing one
yes stage yes it was they don't stop
can't stop I tried to get the stinger
out because I couldn't find it I'm like
all right [ __ ] it you're like that's a
myth right like because it's pulsing and
then but once it pulses all the Venom
then you're good right you keep walking
now that is Grizzly territory there are
Grizzlies oh yeah so I was like you know
head on a swivel and you're in sandals
Daddy I'm In sandals so stupid I don't
mind hiking in sandals because it's just
it's just stupid right I know it's your
business but yeah can you imagine me
hiking with a bottle of tiger thick yeah
you got it was like what's the point
that's the same thing right well you
know my feet felt free though Brandon
and it's just not it's not for that yeah
what if you guys made a hiking sandal
now you're talking who has that
like there's TVs who I think there's an
actual sandal for hiking there's TVs
yeah if you make like a monster truck
sandal there's a whole there's rocks
there's a lot there's actually a lot
and then uh oh yeah so oh those are for
hiking yes sir no I'm saying you make
like a stylish I weigh perfect those are
all gay right like you only seen it
though look at those yeah those are look
at those those aren't sexy no your
pronouns are not uh him and he and if
you're rocking those right those are
yeah those are pronouns are they them
those are you do have to have a copy of
the Communist Manifesto in your hand
when you are hiking now if you're
wearing those you're tucking your dick
you're talking right they do come with a
tick tock they come with a gives you
instructions on how to tuck your dick
it's good they have a it's a soft rope
it's a soft rope they have hemp rope to
keep you honest if you want if you want
an organic package when you buy those
sandals at REI you're like what's the
tape for like oh then it comes so you
can tape your dick back yeah oh thank
you yeah and it's waterproof too so have
fun yep and this is this is the ball
press it's a ball press what is that for
it presses your ball into your [ __ ]
and uh that way you can you can hike
properly but what if you guys made like
a dope like stylish like monster like
the way you're thinking like a meaty
bottom a meaty bottom leather top call
them meaty bottoms dude the meats
they're called the meats you're hiking
the meats yeah I get the meats the hike
dude mud Yellow Jackets whatever we'll
be dope
I like that a lot now that's gonna need
what I gotta get my beak wet on there
dude but these shoes these saw a lot
dude the thick boy meets
sounds like it only benefits you
know
yeah but Tacoma yeah Tacoma was great
great Club
Great crowds most tickets I've ever sold
spoken yeah
great man it's a big room too yeah it's
great I loved it the green rooms are
dope they have all the candy and arcades
all the green rooms are the same I
facetimed my kids I was like it's such
okay
I'm not a candy guy I ate a shitload of
candy I don't mess with them I ate all
the candy sprees I had to taste I would
open a Rolo can I eat a [ __ ] Tic Tac
then I ate a Twix Twix are [ __ ] good
they're great Market all the [ __ ]
kids so Jay eats the candy too I don't
touch it well it's like no candy oh cool
more for me yeah well daddy's been
daddy's been going heavy with my
bodybuilder Nick Simmons who's our
bodybuilder who who did the night 120s
for nine yeah and by the way everybody
who is like I can do that they were
doing they were doing incline including
you buddy you got to be he was sitting
straight up doesn't matter he's on a
shoulder press where were you on Mark uh
well everybody was doing this they were
all doing that the incline you can't we
can't have that and we can't but no it
doesn't matter I was actually on a
different seat so you're the one that
I'm on ends here I mean you could bring
up a video of it you know but like bring
up a video it's only about the Motions
okay also you can see mine from the side
I'm not looking at his back
let's see let's see I look like this you
naturally if the seat ends here it's
like a small one oh yeah yeah you can
lean over you know oh it's a small one
that's straight up yes that's what he's
calling it marked on shoulder press then
okay okay he's saying the angle of my
back is different if you're going on a
bench that goes all the way up here it
prevents your back from going back but
also again yeah I'm gonna be defensive
here because it is it's all about angles
he's got me he's got me doing the
bodybuilder [ __ ] my my appetite yeah
I'll eat all the food yeah yeah I don't
realize when you go heavy like that I'll
eat everything yep you'll eat it I'm
getting thick yeah
if you want to see my Instagram
you look exactly the same though yeah no
no no matter what no I'm wearing a
sweatshirt to keep things together you
know that you know that though you look
at you guys you know what I mean though
right there right there
that's Chad Schmidt who is the manager
Big Boy Kevin chat we've got Nick
Simmons all right Brendan you said that
you my list is not impressive you said
you could do 120 pounds easy and I'm not
a bodybuilder I'm just a guy who likes
Fitness so you should be able to out
doing me easy so no that's not true
let's see if you can challenge on you
you have a couple I said to him I go
Brandon doesn't give a [ __ ] Brandon does
not give a [ __ ] he's not even gonna see
this I'm excited I look great tonight
second attempt okay play pause it pause
it say pause it
let me do this
you know wristbands on you got wrist
straps on so don't count hold on hold on
don't count the first time he didn't and
he only did nine this is a second
attempt and he goes my wrist gave out do
you have any wrist Reps don't count but
he did this he did this nine times don't
matter without respect doesn't matter I
understand that oh now hold on don't
count he did it without wristbands I
only see wristbands that's the second
attempt no it doesn't matter he took two
minutes doesn't matter
he we I can show you I'm saying uh now I
don't know what level of athleticism
Athletics he's done but at University of
Colorado yeah no wristbands no no back
belts none of that well he did this
exactly don't matter without the amount
I don't see it two minutes before I
don't see it come on I don't believe you
what I don't believe you call me a liar
100 dude yeah sorry that's an outrage
yes you can't just you can't just
dismiss it
wristbands let me see it let me see him
do it for a sec he has some shoulders on
though he does he's got some he skips
leg day though huh no no he's got big
one
too let's go
push it
push it
[Music]
hey who's the guy going push it yeah
push it good
this is the second attempt but he did
nine before
those eight yeah
okay we're in uh now go back go back to
the other one
oh there's my crazy I mean Mark's a
little bit more oh no that's shoulder
press Bubba 100 that looks like uh
incline no no no no no yeah no that's it
the same one don't be mad at am I wrong
I'll explain because
I'll explain but no that makes sense
actually now that I should be impressed
by myself
my walking shoulder goes that I promise
no but I hear you I see it I see what
you're saying all I'm saying is I'm not
trying to defend like the I will go back
and do perfectly upright no that I I get
it the difference in Implement he has a
higher back I like to have the
flexibility in my upper back but that
that tends to make you lean back a
little bit okay yeah I also like doing
behind the neck press because that you
can't cheat you know yeah like so again
Nick's very strong dude yeah I'm proud
of that lift I'm not comparatively
strong given how big I am but I think
bench is his big thing the behind the
neck is so hard on my shoulders
Oh I thought this was exercising
that looks really really
should buy it because it should well it
frames your face
the Buckle doesn't fit my chicken but
it's only if you fly an outdoor plane
only if you fly outside outdoor plane
there you go that looks so good you
should have bought it you guys were just
having fun
we should hunt rabbits from that Alaska
we wabbits yeah I liked it there well
quarter Lane's [ __ ] beautiful okay
but wait Brad what did you do on the did
you do shoulder press how many how much
nothing like that I'm not saying I'm
just interested in how heavy I I went 40
the last thing I did was just four yeah
that's good you know eight or something
for your size that's good you know what
I'm I'm like I'm weak I can't do
anything but I did like so when I was
doing a bent over row with the with the
pulling it this way so I did I think two
45s plus a 25. that's okay seven times
you can go heavy with like batches yeah
like seven times seven times oh yeah
yeah but I'm not strong I'm [ __ ] not
strong you're good for your age though
I'm sure you know but I don't think I'm
not built for strength I'm not yeah
that's not your thing no you guys are
like you're [ __ ] weird strong like
that some people just have that I'm not
I look stronger than I actually am like
people always assume I'm stronger than I
am but uh like Brendan's more naturally
strong did you see Bradley Martin
holding that girl and she slipped and
kicked him in the face I did I was like
oh boy is it on his yes
he's weird I only saw it because on
Worldstar yeah he's weird strong
you know he's the girl slips and kicks
him right in the [ __ ] face yeah
Bradley is very strong I'll also say
he's been lifting consistently for a
very long time so that's something like
I always think of Brendan train for like
a year at the bench press doing that he
dug some basketball like he's reaching
this is not
[Music]
yeah that's gonna hurt your face so yeah
people hit me up right afterwards like
that they were they were there they're
like things got real awkward
oh wait hit his head too right that's a
serious kick I mean at least he's still
got it done yeah he's a beast yeah
and that's really risk so people said it
was awkward after everyone thought Yeah
well yeah like he was like not happy
apparently you know it's like yeah if
you just got like a slap in the face of
the 45 I'd be laughing man first of all
I'd be embarrassed is she okay but I
guess they did it successfully before it
turned the other way and then for some
reason they turned it towards like she
was facing the other way it's so
impressive because to bench that which
is if this was on the bar it's not that
much weight because she's probably about
130 and yeah 45 so it's only like 200
pounds but then just the Dynamics of her
moving and you do that yeah and Angeline
is really sweet too I know she's yeah
she's sharing more about it that's not
her fault that's a dangerous move the
reason we watch it is because it's like
I'm not saying it's a fart but like
she's the type of person she's like
feels bad about is that Gronk look at
how big Gronk is it's not wrong not get
younger that Steve will do it who is
that oh my God
who is who is Steve he's one of the top
bodybuilders oh my God he's a giant no
this is he's a YouTuber they took him
off YouTube
[Music]
yeah this is his real oh I'm sorry
yeah he's like one of the top YouTubers
oh
you thought it was ground cone I did
it
looks huge that looks like gronkers they
have similar faces they do yeah and he
wears like a Gronk Jersey why wouldn't I
think that was five six no that's the
only difference well not so the
superimposed his head yeah that was
Photoshop I think it was yeah swap yeah
they took him off of uh he got kicked
off uh because in his bio he put uh a
betting site which is frowned upon they
literally took he had like seven million
subscribers who just took it from until
he makes money
took it from so he has to like petition
is Nate I mean is Ender tape back on
YouTube yeah I think he is right then
look I don't know he's on I don't know
if he had an official YouTube channel
that's the only thing so people post him
correct and that was part of his
Hustler's universities he goes here's
access to this database of Clips if you
pay this much money a month you can
license all the food that you want and
make your own videos to make a YouTube
channel and get your own money
so you can find them all over it's just
yeah I don't think he has his own
channel
I don't think they're allowing them back
on me that's why he went over to rumble
yeah what's Facebook Rumble is gonna be
a real competitor oh the ring the bell
at the NASDAQ on Friday in New York
yep
we had our Floyd Dave Rubin on yep
an early investor I think big time I
can't believe he they offered you you
just were like [ __ ] it yeah I don't yeah
I know I didn't have the money I never
know either yeah yeah oh yeah that's
what he said yeah but it's a good book
yeah I don't think Andrew Tate's back on
YouTube but he's uh he's doing this
thing on Rumble and he's all he's still
all over he's one of those guys
yeah and his demographic of
find them yeah I'm not worried about
them
at all 100 percent
yeah man
I sat next to uh
what I think was a very wealthy man on
the plane I assumed we talked I figured
it out he was uh
you know he's like a big time donor and
a fundraising guy who like he had a
fundraiser for DeSantis and oh he's uh
up the Church of Latter-day Saints music
from the church of Latter-day Saints
um and uh like a Mormon you know older
man very nice really good [ __ ] guy
and smart as [ __ ] she tried recruiting
you into them no he just he broke down
the Book of Mormon that was very
interesting I'd never had that broken
down for me sometimes it's nice when you
have a flight and it's a good
conversation it makes the time go by
fast yep he had a book he was reviewing
called Atomic habits and uh he was
talking about what he does I assume this
is in first class yeah it was like what
he does for his first day his first day
I mean I'm sorry to wake up when he
wakes up first thing in the morning and
uh what do you say pray to God well
there's a whole bunch of stuff he does
and you know it's it's just like some
people are so buttoned down and they can
do that that you know he studies
scripture he works out for half hour he
gets his green juice older he's older
and he looked great and he was a [ __ ]
smart great guy really well read really
interesting I was so tired I was so
[ __ ] exhausted I couldn't like he was
telling me about the Book of Mormon that
was what I oh he just started talking
and you went to sleep well I I had a
great conversation with him but then I
just I after an hour I was like I can't
turn my head this much and I'm you're
like literally I I I just had to sleep I
don't have the energy dude yeah but he
was really impressive dude I started
watching I didn't know it came back
so he's he's a member of the Republican
National Party
and uh
he said he's in the minority but he
doesn't think Trump's going to run that
was interesting I was like wow
very interesting
so I was like that's an interesting
inside scoop you know and he didn't
really go into it but I was like believe
it we've had other people are closer to
the ties to Trump who tells he is yeah
if you remember yeah big names yeah who
knows I know I bet he does I mean he
does I think yeah on the plane I started
I didn't know this I always try to
either have a book or download some [ __ ]
and I went to Netflix I'm like let's see
what's on there and there's new Jeffrey
Dahmer series on there oh it's good dude
really if you know the Jeffrey Dahmer
story it's so [ __ ] good he was
horrific huh he would show you pictures
of what he had done to his previous
victims while you were tied up
uh not really he didn't tie people up he
might be this doesn't sound awful he
might be the most impressive serial
killer because he only killed men like
everybody else uh gay men yeah but they
were they weren't like small dudes like
he wouldn't pick on you because you're
small or whatever he only killed dudes
you look at all the other serial killers
they're going for like women well after
he killed him but he was going like
every other serial killers going for
like women or people sleeping now
granted Jeffrey would drug them so
they're you know out of it and they'd
kill him but he killed some without the
drugs but he would just keep drugging
people yeah but even do weird things if
you've gotten through it
he always wanted to watch
um so funny he always wanted to watch uh
the oh what the Exorcist you want to
watch The Exorcist really he'll make you
watch The Exodus with them seriously
yeah that's something yeah he would
drill the holes in your head and stuff
he did a lot of weird [ __ ] well he
wanted you know why like he wanted to
create a zombie because he wanted his
whole thing was so
and they don't think it's his child his
upbringing you know a lot of them think
of his relationship like his family was
good but he said himself his own words
was I was just born different I was
always different I've always felt this
way it's not my parents no so his mom
and dad got divorced when he was like 16
and then his mom just left him when he
was 18. just dipped out so he lived in
the house by himself that's where he
killed his first victim but he was 18.
Mom just took off he just always felt
different she probably was like yes
people pick up on that [ __ ] yeah and she
had another family another kid she moved
on and then he uh
he was just the odd ball man just never
fit in so he was trying to create a
zombie person that's why he drilling the
head and put hot water in there because
he wanted to create a zombie-like person
because he would get really angry when
people would leave him like whenever he
would leave him he'd freak the [ __ ] out
and that's when he killed him and he
thought by killing him they would stick
around like one guy he killed and then
burned all his bike bones and smashed
him up and then put all the ashes of the
bones around the house he's like I just
want to feel him like he's with me all
the time that's why he started eating
him he started eating people because he
thought that would make him feel like
they're with him like he just had this
horror like he hated that people like
[ __ ] like he would freak out if
they'd like go to work like he'd hook up
with these gay dudes and then they'd
wake up more like I gotta go to work
you're like what the [ __ ] but it's
Tuesday dude I go to work he's killed
mm-hmm
and when they caught him he's like you
need to kill me like I said you have no
idea how bad yeah he was like I'm not
and he was like and there's no cure like
you got to kill me here's the bummer and
the more they touch on a little bit in
the series but the Milwaukee Police they
had so many opportunities to stop him
yeah like the neighbor called several
times like dude I'm telling this guy's
dead bodies in the house they just
ignored her uh the the young kid who was
14 his youngest victim was 14. he's
reading dude he got away and was on the
streets the cops grabbed him put him
back when Jeffrey Dahmer's arms and the
neighbor and her kids were like no
that's a child he's clearly not all
there you're gonna let this guy and
Jeffrey Dahmer so Charming he was like
it's my boyfriend go in my house go in
my apartment I have pictures meet him
together he's got he drank too much and
cop's like yeah you're good go with him
like there's so many opportunities to
stop him kill that kid oh he's the only
drilling this head
and then also what's crazy about that is
he Jeffrey Dahmer went to prison or jail
before that because that kid he molested
his cousin who was 18 years prior so he
did he did like a stent in jail because
he molested the kid
his first murder he's driving down the
road drunk going back and forth cop
pulling over he has a dead body in his
back seat but then he cut it up so it
was in trash bags and the cop was like
what is that he's like oh it's leaves I
can't sleep so I decided to rake up all
the leaves and cops like that makes
sense have a good day go ahead
oh [ __ ] man is it nuts [ __ ]
they had so many opportunities to stop
and they just never did yeah you just
because you don't think as a cop you're
dealing with one of the great monsters
you're not dealing with a cannibal when
I look at the average guy I'm not
thinking this person eats people right
and I mean but still you have to be on a
little bit like enough warnings and then
also he was staying with his grandma and
put that's where he killed like eight
dudes in the basement and they'd store
the bodies so the human carcass smells
like one of the worst smells in the
world we're literally wired to be like
yes we hate that smell dead corpses when
the cops smell like the cops were asking
like the smell of the dead bodies in
your apartment like they had complaints
for years that they smelled so bad from
Neighbors and he was he's so [ __ ]
crazy he didn't the smell he didn't
repulse him he was like oh I don't I
don't smell anything they're like you
don't smell those dead bodies yeah
that's that's a guy with something
missing you know there are people like
I've had uh Rogan's really good at
picking out something off on the person
like he's really good at going I don't
want to be around on that guy he's all
I've never seen him be wrong at the end
yeah I mean sometimes maybe you know but
but I had I knew a girl who could do
that who was
she could just [ __ ] be in a bar I
mean we were in a bar and we had like
our bags and this girl goes
I don't like that guy
and I go what do you mean she goes that
guy right there at the bar
I don't like the way that guy's looking
over here
and I go
well you're a [ __ ] crazy person and
you're uh but she just had the radar she
just had the radar and you tried to
steal somebody's purse and he was with a
girl and he was a regular looking guy
good looking guy actually and she just
picked up on the way he was standing but
Jeffrey dummy he got kicked out of the
bath house he got kicked out of the bars
because he got known to be the guy that
drugged everybody so he drugged people
and one guy OD'd but they saved him so
they kicked him out all these bars man
did everything go in there did I tell
you this so I tried to write a TV show
about um there was a brothel in new and
uh Venice
um it was it was uh they would give you
a rub and tug you know one of those
things and I knew I one of the girls was
a fan of the show I did so I said I want
to write a show about your oh and write
a show about you this this [ __ ] this
rub Club yeah you don't have to do some
yeah in person experimenting you are
yeah but this girl could this these
women
had such [ __ ] radar
first of all they knew that if that they
were targeted to be robbed because they
couldn't go to the cops
okay so if anybody found out that what
this house was they were gonna get
robbed they were way more afraid of that
than the cops
secondly you always attract freaks
and so so back then you would put an ad
in the paper Okay and she would see an
ad of a girl who had a choker collar on
kneeling looking up
and if she knew that girl she'd go take
that [ __ ] picture down now does that
attracted crazy it no it attracts
dangerous men yes because now you're
gonna dominate yeah because she's that's
a dangerous man yeah yeah take the
picture of this way and guys who like
that make sure that's that so then then
they'd see a guy come in and they could
they would what would they do
immediately hug him and then a girl
would come behind and hug him from
behind
like high and they give him a big hug
from behind why were they doing that
because they were checking with their
body to see if he had a weapon on his
body if he did they had a whole system
where they would go hold on and they
would walk him out push him out lock the
door behind them and say we have to just
make her you came a little early and
they'd have a thing and then they'd keep
him there and call somebody a guy who
was like a guy who can handle it yeah
but there was a whole system
that she said she could tell by the
temperature of someone's skin she could
tell by the way they whether their arms
were moving when they walked so they
would watch you walk up they could see
how you walk they'd have to develop
those senses because they're dealing
with the darkest and you can see when
you do that for a living you can if
you're smart the way my friend was you
can pick up on [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] if they're walking and
their arms aren't moving if their body's
stiff which is that they would see that
they'd see a guy walking with his arms
like England they were like that [ __ ]
dude's not coming in here he's got his
he's way too rigid in his body so
something's up he's not connect yeah
because you know you're going in for a
Good Time Charlie you're not me all
stiff yeah
I bet all that kind of stuff all that
kind of stuff but they had all these
safety they would have to have those uh
senses though to [ __ ] survive yeah
that's like those serial killer uh
profilers who can look at a crime scene
and go this guy had a stutter what no he
was in his 30s he had a stutter
yeah no it's just no you give yourself
away you give yourself away there are so
many behavioral traits
that you know
that you do so did you ever write the
you never wrote the show
I did I've written a lot of TV shows
none of which got made because at the
end of the day Brennan I'm a really good
stand-up comic I'm not a good writer I
said it you know why it's really hard to
be a really good writer yeah
writers out there that never gets picked
up yeah it is a hustle and it's all they
do a great screenplay I think is as hard
as building the most intricate [ __ ]
Tower
that [ __ ] is like structurally that's
impossible yeah throat problem huh you
have a little cold to you Daddy got a
little bit cold caught it from you no I
don't know you had it last time
you were all sick oh
we all do this Brandon yeah
um we'll see you got it from traveling
how many people did you see none of us
like to be admit we're sick but how many
people did you see this is the call
going around you had it maybe
I'm like I'm fine
I'm totally fine you should throw a
problem no I'm
oh Daddy's diarrhea went away finally I
thought I was gonna [ __ ] my grandma's
funeral man oh I didn't know you had
diarrhea oh I was just Gosling Pepto
just like that's right what was that
from
uh food truck Seafood food truck that's
a problem don't eat ahi tuna from a food
truck lesson learned
you don't want to do that oh man my ass
was raw God God it was exhausting really
just explain once it's go time it's you
know it's not up to you man it ain't up
to you
them the rules it ain't up to you it
ain't up to you when it's time to go I
was like man I told my grandma if I make
it through this funeral [ __ ] in my pants
I did though shout out to Pepto-Bismol
yeah he ever destroy an airplane
bathroom just be like every time and
then I pretend I'm on a phone I've been
I pretend that they're gonna think oh
he's on a call that's what he's saying
there's someone because they get on like
you do what it didn't make sense
that makes sense but they don't think
it's responses are illegal that's really
damn that's crazy no but yeah no I'm
coming out right now I know I stayed in
there way too long I'll see you yeah
everyone's like I'm sorry about that but
they don't think yeah sorry I destroyed
the bathroom oh dude I was in the Laugh
Factory on Saturday night and I just had
to take a piss and I went to the
bathroom somebody
did destroyed that bathroom I go in and
I take this I'm holding my nose pee Oh
my God it's just this bombshell weekend
and I was like
whoever did that was before me yeah and
she went yeah and I'm like oh she and
I'm big and I was like sweaty I'm like
oh she thinks it's me I know she thinks
it's I hate that so much like I swear it
wasn't me I want to be a kid tell me
that you don't think it's me I want to
take your handbook real quick I want you
to tell me that you don't think you know
I didn't do that you know I just told
you the story yeah dude somebody
destroyed that thing yeah that's so
frustrating my friend you couldn't I
I've never forget this me and my buddy
talking to this girl and she was like I
can't find a [ __ ] good guy she was
just like this
I can't find a guy and this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] I gotta take a [ __ ] like you
care
my buddy guys well there It Is Well Jen
I wonder why you can't find a guy he's
like [ __ ] you no no I'm about to
yeah don't I don't want to hear about
that but yeah
Mark went back home this weekend yes I
did you did saw Mama you saw everybody
yep I drove uh basically 24-hour
turnaround I drove at 100 miles an hour
at 3am you know Saturday night came back
this morning so I came straight from
Northern California how far of a drive
400 miles
so try to do about five hours yeah wow
that's not terrible no it's actually
really nice in the middle of the night
and I listened to uh that book uh
blitzed on the way here what is it
called it's called Blitz it's all about
methamphetamines the Nazis taking it
they couldn't figure out how they're
like traveling through the night and
like not sleeping they realized on God
too I didn't realize it was like in
society first like you could just go and
get methamphetamine at the store like
Pez they didn't know yeah oh yeah you
know just like anything yeah I'm
listening to [ __ ] uh chantaram
which is a novel I haven't listened I
haven't read a novel in so long but you
got to read novels what's it about yeah
it's a true story about a guy who did he
got he got
um he lost custody of his daughter and
his wife leaves him big guy and he he
[ __ ] uh
he breaks out of an Australian prison
gets 20 years for armed robbery 20 years
because he got into drugs breaks out
and goes and just like as a fugitive
under a fake name goes to Bombay to
India and if you know anything about
Bombay you might want to bring up aerial
images of Bombay the [ __ ] he becomes
a Smuggler he becomes a criminal there
he finds the criminal element in Bombay
and that is where like everything is
that's where all the afghanis all the
everybody everybody converges into
Mumbai Bombay and it is
God it's it's a city if there was ever a
city that that would be worn out it is
so crowded with miles of shanty towns
miles of shanty you know the Peaks we're
getting looks pretty lit no that's not
that's terrible go to Bombay aerial view
please that's the way you did it looked
nice there yeah well it looked really
cool but I would put in Bombay slums
yeah yeah or they're there right there
go to that last one yeah right there
last on the first one yeah right there
now you see all that that's all
makeshift housing those are the slums of
Bombay yeah
like [ __ ] New York yeah it's a huge
City I mean you know and there's
obviously great parts of it it's it's a
place if you know how to navigate is you
know is got its own magic so hot
you know so many people don't have
running water I mean it's it's I don't
know how it's the third world country
yeah yeah but India is becoming a
Powerhouse in so many [ __ ] ways I
mean amazing but but at the same time
they have come through some crazy [ __ ]
um they they weren't able to feed their
population in the 70s and 80s good book
though oh man it's it's such a good
thing to it yeah he wrote it in jail
when he was in jail
is he doing the voiceover I know oh I
hate that the actor's amazing I don't
like that no the acting you have to have
something really knows how to do the
accent it's better when it's not natural
this one this one this is
shondaram you you would you probably get
obsessed with it I I I wouldn't
recommend it it's one of the best books
anybody who reads a lot like like kind
of just kind of goes they go oh yeah I
really love it yeah that's like it's
like the it's an All-Star it's it's an
Epic Novel
[ __ ] Jim what do you got buddy
all right thank you to the t5k Army
because we found that post
this is um
the last Theodore's last message we
didn't look at MMA we did we did you
know my memory was it was his face with
the words on it so when I saw just this
I thought it was something else but
anyways we found him I'd like the memory
of me to be a happy one I'd like to
leave an aftergrow of smiles when the
day is done I'd like to leave an echo
with spring softly down the ways of
happy times and laughing times and
bright and sunny days
I'd like the tears of those who grieved
to dry before the sun
of happy memories that I leave behind
when the day is done
that's such a shame yeah yeah man he
wrote that um
Jesus Christ
[ __ ] yeah
yeah
it really sucks
oh she found the post of Jesus Christ
thank goodness damn dude you know it's
funny it was nowhere else though it's
just like right here yeah yeah okay uh
I'm surprised someone posted on his wall
yeah is this donkey is this yes this has
to be the one right this is donkey
Revenge did the fan send it to you no I
found this one
he's just kicking the donkey for no
reason and trying to ride it and punch
it yeah why is he playing oh now because
he's biting him but then good
you're kidding that donkey in the
[ __ ] face dude
yeah what a douchebag
that donkey's like what the hell are you
doing he slaps him too what the f he's
trying to break its spirit
[Music]
I don't know if that's how you do it no
he's an [ __ ]
[Music]
it's a piece of [ __ ]
or a donkey I can't wait for this donkey
get back at him I'd be so nice that
donkey
why is the music so intense I know I
don't like the music a piece of [ __ ]
yeah he's probably don't be in the show
because he wants to ride him he thinks
that's the way you break it finally that
donkey got his ass
yes donkey
donkey step on him
good dog is that the donkey screaming or
somebody else
it's probably somebody else no that's
him screaming look at the ground and see
his face I hope it's him that's
screaming yeah it is a piece of [ __ ]
God barking man yeah good thing is
probably didn't hurt the dog he hits
like a [ __ ] dude
have you guys seen this one yet
this is a Canadian school teacher that
turned trans about a year ago and this
is how she now identifies as this person
with those gigantic overly sized
Prosthetics and she can just wear those
tits this person for the implants no
Prosthetics but this is a mentally
Disturbed person and that she's allowed
to teach so she's protected yeah and the
school the school board is uh protecting
her right now because this is who she
identifies as I mean
and all the parents just be cool and
then in America they want to fire
teachers that do only fans but then if
you're doing this it's this is where it
gets all crazy so these are funny
they're fake tips and they're
transgender they're giant nipples
is it transgender too it says trans but
I don't know if she had surgery or not
yeah
yeah well um
I don't know it's just mentally ill like
you wouldn't want her teaching your kids
no that's not that has nothing to do
with trans that looks like a mentally
old person yep also like why are you
doing that who's it for what attention
do you want what so I don't like great
she teaches but you just want to get
these big tits out in front of the kids
I think it's prosthetic it's fake tits
yeah she didn't get those done she's
wearing it that's what makes it even
worse yeah same part of her body I
wonder if she's doing it as an
experiment what is she is she protesting
it I wonder if she's actually mocking
like she might be going really okay I'm
gonna do this let's see what you guys do
now that looks that looks like somebody
who's trying to say we've got we've done
but then this this is actually someone
who identifies as trans so yeah but
that's what you would say this kid the
kids care most definitely don't think
it's normal but realistically what can
we say I don't think the school can fire
the teachers identified as a man last
year so he's just like this is how I
dress would you be distracted by the
Prosthetics well I think this this
person's trying to make a point that's
right I don't think so I think you're
giving it you think they're a
performance artist
essentially I think because why would
why would the T why would the the even
if she was trying to make a point the
school board wouldn't put up with that
the reason she's allowed to get with
through it they think it's organic
can I tell you something uh that relates
to this will Franken is a brilliant
comic uh who's in the UK and for a year
he dressed up as Sarah Franken or he
said I'm transitioning I think he went
on Rogan yeah did he I think will
Franken I think so yeah I know he he was
on Marin I don't know if I've seen I
don't think I've seen the rugged episode
but uh he and then just like he he did
it he never acknowledged that it was a
troll job but like he
does it have any pictures if you look up
will Franken committee comedian
um but he's like a brilliant satirist
and Franken not Franklin yeah
um he's a brilliant status from the Bay
Area who I knew from back from living
there and he he did it and he did like
interviews with it where he played a
totally straight face and like people
loved him like oh this guy comes out and
like yeah you know and then just drops
it and goes that's not me anymore it
didn't say anything no one could do [ __ ]
you can't do so to that point it's like
he was exposing and he's done like
my skeptical hip is with that teacher
that teacher's up to something I don't
think so the school board will allow it
well but the school board can't can't do
anything do anything because it's a very
touchy subject so what I think they're
doing is going so over the time yeah I
think that's we'll see what happens with
it yeah you're either completely crazy
or you're doing it to to school the
issue too is I guess apparently she's a
really good teacher all the kids love
the class too so she's a good teacher
doing her job yeah
interesting it's just a little
distracting I think I'm telling you I'd
be furious I saw the way she was looking
at the camera and I just see sanity in
those eyes I'm like there's something
there's a wink in the nod now there's a
wink and a knot the tits are a little
too big and the nipples are the the
biggest problem and the top like you
know what you're doing well you guys
turned on I was a little turned on a
little bit
but that's that to me is uh clearly
something going on I bet you that that
person has an amazing sense of humor
and the makeup's not bad either I was
looking at that going okay all right not
you know it's not a crazy person putting
on makeup but somebody who knows what
looks good
it's insane oh that's just insane
but this is what you get and you're
gonna get people you're going to get
Mischief Makers you're going to get
people let's start honest see I don't
get that out oh I think I do I think
we're gonna find that make a note of
that uh-oh oh this is Justin run posted
this I guess this driver is really
amazing at driving reverse while this
elephant's chasing her yeah
he's going backwards backwards
oh [ __ ] you can't stop oh he's nice with
it
look at how fast I'm calm
he's just staring at the rear view I'm
like all right
yes you stopped that everybody's gonna
get [ __ ] well it'll turn the Jeep over
finally the healthy yeah it'll turn the
Jeep over
yeah
that guy's so scared he's like what the
[ __ ]
yep hey you guys wanted a [ __ ] Safari
man
oh it's a whole group of people yeah
it's a whole Safari that's what you
wanted so far you don't want just a
normal animal [ __ ] you want a little
excitement yeah a lion jumps in takes
somebody yeah
I saw this on SportsCenter and I thought
it was pretty cool so you're supposed to
go run across that log and grab the flag
at the very end of it
[Music]
I want to look at the music yeah so it
is slick oh [ __ ]
oh that looks so hard wow especially
with that long oh oh switch the oh that
was the logs wet
oh no no that's all so you can't go
backwards no yeah no oh keep going keep
going it's nuts
oh oh oh yeah nobody gets a chin I know
oh my God
oh I think the closest one yeah boy I
could watch this all day oh dude you had
it yeah I could watch that all day yeah
you have to run though
yeah you can't walk yeah
um impossible let's do this one real
quick for what wait you wanna see us
first yeah
I don't know if it's more like you know
being
sarcastic but so Peter's saying like
they should stop if you're if you're a
wife or girlfriend you should withhold
sex if your husband or boyfriend
continues to eat meat I know but what do
I do about people who don't eat red meat
a lot of times who look that white and
that unhealthy that's a vampire just
curious you want to hear your [ __ ]
blood
she's Dr Carrie Bennett from Peta and
she
well she has all the teeth right between
men and women's diets
and yes
and sent higher carbon footprint because
they're mostly eating a lot more meat
than women I mean we should be looking
at this and it actually has significant
implications
it isn't just Peter saying that people
should eat less meat and go vegan it's
the United Nations oh my God the United
Nations plant-based diets that's gonna
help the climate and it'll also stop
deforestation pandemics pollution and a
whole house pandemic so it's going to
start pandemics you start being mean by
you hear that she's an expert good
expert also single right so that's why
she's like boycott the men and husbands
she looks She's Single and there's seven
cats in the background she looks very
happy there's seven cats you have all
the teeth
oh do you remember this guy
yeah I love Billy Gardell Billy Gardell
he lost a ton of weight so that's him
with uh Billy's crate yeah he's on that
show
um Mike and Molly he looks fantastic
yeah dude he looks completely different
now you man you look awesome thank you
brother I went from a young Jackie
Gleason to an old Paul Newman
he's but yeah just a [ __ ] great dude
and he does look amazing
he's hilarious that dude he's a legit
monster oh my God
I I did the San Jose Improv with him I
don't know 12 13 years ago and I had to
be president oh I mean crushed it he's
one of the greats dude he's Billy
Gardell is a [ __ ] monster so you were
headlining and then he featured no we
were on a tour and I can't remember the
circumstances but I remember watching
him going oh my Lord I gotta follow this
guy I have a dick monster monster I mean
he's just so special
yeah yeah
all right Mark what do we got here so
Aaron Rodgers I guess he's being a
little bit Coy about what exactly he saw
but he blames the recent Victory uh over
the bucks on the Jumbotron so the
interview afterwards and they said they
showed it on the previous play too uh if
you if you it was a delay on both plays
sometimes you see things in the game
sometimes the Jumbotron shows things
they probably shouldn't show even at
home I saw something and just passed on
I wonder what it was
yeah you know about this interview look
at the hair sticking out he looks insane
because his hair's his long hair and
it's sticking just like a bird out the
side can we watch that he he was can you
tell me I saw a clip he said I'm too
[ __ ] they're too I'm working with
children I'm too old and I'm working
with children and he's eating and he
looks drunk did you see that clip no in
a press conference no oh it was crazy
you gotta you'll see it I was like huh
too [ __ ] young I'm too [ __ ] old
I'm working with [ __ ] children he's
eating I don't know it was so weird
they're probably going after him they do
the left goes after him one place clip
real quick yeah oh you come all the way
down and talk to him his hair drives me
nuts final drive with the defense on
what was going through you during the
two-point conversion especially after
you saw the fact that they took the
five-yard penalty well they showed it on
the previous play too it was a delay on
both plays but uh
sometimes you see things in the game
sometimes a Jumbotron shows things they
probably shouldn't show even at home I
saw something I just passed on bar still
says Aaron Rodgers got the Bucks
Jumbotron guy fired
I wonder what that was what would that I
want to see I don't know what would that
be automation or something I don't know
yeah
I'm too old and what was it
what's that you said uh the clip says
Aaron Rodgers says I'm too old and
they're I'm working with kids
you okay bro yeah what's going on hey
man I'm working with kids watch this
I was trying to find what it was
no keep going
it's a clear I'm getting oh no
oh anyways where'd you see that be Tick
Tock some [ __ ] yeah just shorts
all right dude yeah yeah great guy
this one here Mark no yeah
but it's not what you think if you're
just looking at the headline so
basically this kid
called in a fake domestic violence call
then points an airsoft rifle at the cops
um he was shot that after repeatedly
calling 9-1-1 to get police to his
family's home claiming that his father
was drunk and beating his mother and him
but nothing was going on like that yeah
and uh try to commit suicide yeah death
by cop here
potentially yeah
um because he's and it's not even like a
colored rifle or whatever it gave any
indication so he is uh you know pointing
this thing to him
um so he was he was intentionally trying
to get shot that's awful that poor kid
that poor kid see but the promise says
you know officer fatally shoots teenager
with airsoft gun it's like yes but the
kid was trying to die by cop and to hold
the gun at the tops yeah it was yeah I
thought it was an interesting headline
given like that's not that I feel bad
for those cops I feel bad for that kid
the family's too it's terrible
it's a terrible current event
[Laughter]
uh here's the video shows restaurant
so this guy comes in after Putin and
that's the main story that I wanted you
guys to talk about was you know Putin's
drafting people so this guy's like oh
yeah and he comes in and shoots the
draft officer with a shotgun holy yeah
he's forced him to drive and there's all
these protests now nobody wants him no
more you're gonna die
yeah can I see that what was that
so if you go to the very beginning in
the upper what a disaster
they'll be fun after this I promise oh I
don't like this
so just the top left
yeah that was it and he didn't shoot
anybody else right just the drafting
officer would you guys that would you
have like gone and tackled or anything
Brian no I he has a shotgun I don't know
what I would do was this uh does he have
a shotgun yeah like this yeah I don't
know I mean I don't know is that shotgun
oh that used to be tough attack guy with
a shot that's a tough so unless you're
so close to him but you have good
lateral movement I could chuck and Jive
zigzag well that's uh shotgun sprays
he's gonna spend time in a Russian
prison my guess is that's not great
it has all this protein are you ready
investing in the protesters too sorry
the fun stuff there's this uh you had
anybody else that gets murdered Mark
yeah this is all just the day of murders
yep well you have that do you have that
one Monday hold on do you have that one
guy yes I do chin as a video right hold
on is it the guy that oh no not this the
guy that uh met the guy off grinder and
he's a hairdresser and then he killed
him hung him upside down and ate his
dick
I thought it was dark Monday no no no no
no no that was dark Monday it's my
Murder My Name murder Monday no it's not
burning Monday anymore no no no no he's
in that no you didn't see that no no no
no it's not it's let's not do it as good
as cocking balls I need it that all
happens sometimes the guys completely
normal whenever you think you're weird
you know people say I'm weird no you're
not there's yeah all grinder date upside
down yeah but this was in 2020 it looks
no no well he just got so that's all
news is it all news though
oh no he looks like uh look at him oh
well yeah that's Rob Zombie
yeah
but wait which one is which I think
there has to be this is I'm gonna go pee
but that's a good question
you said he was a hairdresser
oh you killed the hairdresser yeah it
was hairdresser ain't doing this stuff
this guy did this stuff where's Brian
going
all right just taking a break oh oh
these are good I'm just seeing yeah oh
don't let me get those fantastic yeah so
this raven one is really fun this guy
trained this raven like how smart is
this raven well they're so smart
he's giving him verbal commands to go
get stuff
they're the smartest people
foreign
and the gloves go stuck on the tree go
get it
there's a Rick and Morty episode where
he trained Ravens they're so [ __ ]
smart
device
come on I can't get it get it for me
little Braven what do you think his name
is
um I love them maybe the Raven maybe
well I bet it took forever to train that
[ __ ] thing
they're so intelligent it's crazy that's
his best friend yep
absolutely oh that's cool man oh
so they use tools they'll take oh yeah
they'll take rocks to open up [ __ ] yep
they'll take a bait small animals in
they take they take nuts and they can't
crack them so they let cars run over
them and they'll bake animals in and
stuff to like give like put their food
where they they hide their food yeah
yeah they make fake profiles on Tinder
oh yeah dude they're troll people I
think it counts yeah they're on that
right they're identify as humans on
Reddit That's crazy dude you guys want
the Don Lemon one first oh dude his face
yeah he was not ready this is from this
is all if you've read Thomas Soule who
is a black scholar and a towering
intellect this is what he breaks down in
Black rednecks and white liberals it's
[ __ ] beautiful watch this he was not
ready for this team she was ready to go
oh yeah living a living crisis austerity
budget reparation and then you have
those who are asking uh for reparations
for colonialism and they're wondering
you know 100 billion dollars 24 billion
dollars here and there 500 million there
somebody didn't want to be back and she
gets a grin on her face they're
wondering why are they suffering when
you are you know you have all of this
vast wealth those are legitimate
concerns well I think you're right about
reparations in terms of if people want
it though what they need to do is you
always need to go back to the beginning
where was the beginning of the supplies
that was in Africa and when that crossed
the entire world when slavery was taking
place which was the first nation in the
world that abolished slavery first
nation in the world to abolish it it was
started by William Wilberforce was the
British in in Great Britain they
abolished slavery 2
000 Naval men died on the high seas
trying to stop slavery why because the
African kings were rounding up their own
people they had them on cages waiting in
the beaches no one was running into
Africa to get them and I think you're
totally right if reparations needed
you're totally right we need to go right
back to the beginning of that supply
chain and say who was rounding up their
own people and having them handcrafting
Pages absolutely that's where they
should start and maybe I don't know the
descendants of those families where they
died in the high seas trying to stop the
slavery that those families should
receive something too I think at the
same time
right right well thanks for calling
that's an educated person I mean that's
that's what
Abolitionist Movement began in England
with what we would consider the
equivalent about Evangelical Christians
and they were very organized and got the
British Navy at Great expense uh
monetarily as well to to fight and their
biggest problem the Turks they were
fighting the Arabs they were fighting
because they were the slave trade do you
think she's ready to go you think
nobody's ever brought that up to her
she's like oh I've been down this road
this is a fun game and I agree I love
that I agree 100 she goes you're
absolutely right let's go back to the
supply chain so so other things people
have to understand is that what was
happening was when the white slave
Traders would go into Africa they'd go
into the jungles of Africa they would
die they didn't have the immune system
for the kinds of diseases so he calls
the white man's graveyard yeah so then
they that's where they started getting
the other like like other Africans to
bring them slaves and that's what they
would do
um boy she let him up nothing better
yeah he's just gone [ __ ] smart all right
what is this
I want you to answer this question did
you not call my phone humbly and
peacefully I know it was you
boy yeah I answered the phone I said who
the [ __ ] is this you say it's posted I
said different name I said naked like
that
I guess he was on clubhouse like which
is Audio Only and this girl
just so you know when he's talking all
this [ __ ] on clubhouse he's butt naked
so I brought this up because you love uh
whack 100 right yeah well yeah I did
when I saw him the first time then now
he's just doing it for you know likes
and clout you know it was fun when I
thought it was like real gangster yeah
Takashi 69 I was like oh this guy's
great yeah and then now he's like he's
doing all these interviews like this
guy's not great yeah
talking this clip's amazing because as
you'll see the leopard is just trying to
escape yeah kill anybody he's like get
me the F out of here
well I think he's trying to attack the
guy
leopard wants to kill you it's gonna
kill you
uh well he's taking people down
yeah he wants to leave with your body
[Laughter]
I'd like to have a leopard scar holy
[ __ ]
oh they finally got him in the uh nope
what a thing oh oh [ __ ] oh
they're so athletic oh my god well
they're so athletic
way because it's the set of Aladdin
where is this
holy [ __ ] you're laughing at all those
[ __ ] things yes this looks like
Aladdin yeah he's escaping the goons you
ever see uh what's that Kingdom planet
Earth where the leopards come down into
India into Mumbai no oh dude they come
in they they come right from the hills
and come in and take out dogs babies
yeah a couple people have been killed
but mostly it's like dogs and pigs
remember that one is there that one
Village or city in India where the
Tigers were just like oh we're just
gonna feed on you guys oh well that that
was a huge they made a movie too about
it but the the Lions just come down like
just take people with uh Val Kilmer
right
they will swim out you're in a boat they
will swim out in the water and get in
your boat and kill you do you know that
that's a what a tiger oh that would be a
tiger yeah
you in the sander bonds they think that
that area is where now that's that's
that's a difference but in that sound
about those Tigers they don't know why
but they are
straight up man-eaters yeah straight up
man-eaters and they are could there be
anything scary a tiger a tiger
900 pounds uh yeah well not 900 but
they're huge 400 500. male Lion's 400.
tigers are 780. bring it up
the Bengal tiger is about Bengals
smaller yeah but they're still well it's
500 pounds it's still a huge animal oh
you got a problem it's gonna kill you
you're not doing anything against it and
they look [ __ ] terrifying look at it
Tiger Tiger they're so cool looking but
bro you imagine you got one on your on
your heels and do you want a great book
man-eaters of Kumon it is a true about a
tiger Story the Villager true story
about a tiger Hunter who had to go into
India and find the tigers that were
wreaking havoc in those Villages and
it's his life and they would always call
him and in when my parents were in India
a tiger had killed the equivalent of 246
people one tiger was that efficient so
when they would go out app rubber the
the rubber tree things and they would do
all you know certain parts they would
wear a face on the back of their head oh
yeah because the line won't attack you
yeah so so uh but they you don't hear
them you don't hear them they they jump
on you you're so insane dude that the
the t24 thing is I'm a filmmaker friend
of mine uh Warren made this documentary
about like a man-eater tiger whatever
that was like this notorious tiger in um
in India and it's a true story it's a
true story I only do two stories it's
like a crime Saga I saw somebody
describe it as that new movie The Wild
iron kills a man who enters uh his
territory bring up mayonnaise of Kumon
man eaters yeah lions are I mean [ __ ]
tigers are gnarly yeah how about the
white tiger the Siberian ones that's the
book
that's a really good burger
1944. yeah man it's it's an old book
I love the graphics back then
yeah great book
yeah last Tigers doing tiger [ __ ] dude
yeah
yeah Tigers doing tiger [ __ ] yeah I
guess doing tiger thick that's how
you're doing tiger thick he shot one and
the thing thought the tree in front of
him had done it and it tore the tree up
just [ __ ] tore the tree up and he was
like holy [ __ ] Jesus Christ what else
you got is my hair
my goals that practice there was I think
what really moved the needle what did
you use did you just like get a plastic
bag put some icing and just dunk them in
there I love this black guy process
literally all I did was grab one of
those like flexible ice packs those ones
that sort of Bend and basically because
you applying it directly to your
underwear they don't last long before
training as soon as I woke up and then
also before bed
like 10 to 15 minutes there's literally
every single guy oh yeah because the
guy's so swole doing it um reports
better morning wood better libido and
also we've seen blood work I did my own
blood work before and after and it
definitely moved the needle and what did
it do for you like well I guess just
having typical effects that men talk
about when they go on trts they just
feel confident motivated very so B just
like some big old boss
you're gonna be our guinea pig I can't
do it because I'm taking
so take a cup of ice yeah and water and
just dip them tea bag a cup of ice
that would feel so for Brian's giant
balls that'd be so painful I love the
way this black guy's looking I'm like oh
they're like oh tell us more or really
okay and I like how those two guys are
jacked and this guy just looks like [ __ ]
telling them what to do to boost their
testosterone I'm gonna stick with those
very cool man yeah you don't think
working out and lifting heavy weights
would do that whoever that guy is is a
dummy ah he's selling [ __ ] snake oil
yep
here we go
see this one
oh wait you should probably set it oh
you know I don't know too much about the
actual like I saw our friend the Harry
artist who does some of the promo uh
yeah
um he's awesome he posted this I didn't
know the context I've been trying to
look for it but basically it looks like
they're trying to arrest this guy and
he's not you know saying um maybe I
would assume he's going no I'm not gonna
like put my hands behind my back
use for a double like this guy sprawls
on his ass he's in joggers you seem like
you're guilty and then the cop oh cop
gets wobbled this guy wants to use his
this guy wants to use his technique
I'll tell you right now again the
joggers no punk
shot him with a with
with Taser yeah well this cop he's about
to beat up all four of those guys yes he
was that's where it takes yeah hands
high well he's been taken he's been
taking [ __ ] MMA he shot a double and
he sprawled on the cement yeah Face
action that's right they can fight yes
and then try to fight and the guy was
like pop pop
I got wobbled
and then finally the female cop was like
yeah
that's true she's the one yeah she's
like this is stupid
all that train at the UFC Jim ain't [ __ ]
Jerry that's like Jimmy Burke was about
to fight this guy in a in a restaurant
because the guy bouncer was being so
rude to his mom and tried to take the
chair and uh they were about to go to
blows Jimmy's like [ __ ] you you bet my
[ __ ] you if this guy with Jimmy probably
got beaten up guys but like you and his
his hand just faints
and she's just on the floor oh did you
escalate it God what the [ __ ] yeah they
go the ambulance comes and she goes I'm
fine Jim she goes no you're not we gotta
get you out I'm fine I mean that's
solved or anything it's beautiful and if
you know if you and now here in the
balance imagine if you and I are arguing
yeah
if you would freak out it's a great deal
I'm gonna do that next time I'm gonna do
that my girl it's just me Yama
yeah that's what you do you just you
just faint as it depends man awesome
yeah the old possible no I know
the thing that's
and you just die
and then come back about five minutes
later I'm like oh my God my heart was
flooded yeah my heart and then it just
distracts away from whatever the
argument was deep breath
Brandon we did it again we did it again
guys are we allowed to talk about the
exciting upcoming events this week or
not what events just like our people
what you call me you mean Tacoma this
weekend yeah oh you aren't Tacoma daddy
you love the Pacific Northwest yes right
back up Tacoma Washington this is a
short flight but then after that
I'm traveling
your agent goes hey you've had fun going
Pacific Northwest that's fun right go
all the way across now daddy you're
gonna be doing some drafts all the way
across the country Stress Factory
October Connecticut too it's tough to
get a direct there daddy great club
though Schaumburg Illinois Schaumburg
improv yep that's why I want to deal
with Schaumburg though for me I'm your
agent hey B so you like Chicago right
yeah cool what's not in Chicago so I
want you to fly in Chicago because you
can't fly in Schaumburg I know what
you're driving out so Thursday Friday
it's gonna take you two hours now if
you're Brendan and there's a an active
shooter this could take about four hours
to get there okay so let's go ahead and
or don't if you're Brian and you're on
there and there's a homeless guys trying
to jump into traffic yes from the device
they'll also deliverage that's going to
take that's gonna well well you're gonna
be two hours late active Shooter's good
for taking sales yeah it's very good
people oh let's go out Charlotte North
Carolina Comedy Zone I haven't been
there in a long time can't wait November
10 11 12 and anyway we'll get to that
Booyah I'm in Boston baby my favorite
City Boston this Thursday Friday
Saturday all shows almost sold out we
met at the show on Saturday so get your
tickets now because if I'm gonna add it
I better do it soon uh this Thursday
Friday Saturday Boston laugh Boston and
then I'm in San Jose October 13th
through the 15th San Jose California
Salt Lake City Wise Guys on my favorite
clubs in the nation Wise Guys shout to
Keith and I end October in Calgary at
the rooftop which is located downtown
Calgary Canada October 27th and we're
gonna add a show on the 28th on that
Friday because the 27th film was sold
out so the 28th we're gonna add a show
stay tuned for tickets they might be
live now if you click on it I'm sure you
can figure it out the rooftop Calgary
downtown uh Canada and Calgary all right
but Boston see you this weekend baby I
can't wait yeah it's rare I'm this
excited going to see Boston I love
Boston so you're going on a good time
before it gets impossibly cold always
bring some warm stuff oh yeah oh yeah
you think you still bring warm stuff 100
oh no like coats and [ __ ] well let me
look at the weather daddy will be cold
at night no inside [ __ ] you and guess oh
do you not believe in global warming
trust me buddy
um let me see
let's see here Boston weather
uh okay Thursday 64.
Friday 63 Saturday 68 not terrible how
are we doing tonight uh 45
degrees
all right all right daddy better bring
some wine well I've been waiting for
long sleeve all my all my shit's in long
sleeve
so
booyah
all right is that it all right Boston
see you this week love you guys it's fun
kid we're out